with sci-fi you can get lost in studio
sets we wanted to open up the scope and
get into locations that were cinematic
and beautiful
we went to over a half dozen countries
we went to iceland
the canary islands
malta and ireland
[Music]
where we built a lot of really massive
practical sets
there were so many elements that needed
to work to create these different worlds
the show is massive
there's an insane side to this world
including a planet that's completely
underwater
and action
while other shows may rely on lots of
green screens and virtual sets etc
foundation's actually using physical
sets and that combined with shooting on
locations will give the audience a real
visceral feel that they're in a world
that's been built from the ground up
the story goes to so many different
places
it shows us so many different locations
it takes more power to build than to
burn
and i want to build harry
[Music]
it was a challenge to sort of figure out
how are you going to build things
like trantor is so many layers deep and
then each layer would be
a different architectural style and
cinex being mainly a water world
everything sort of built on stilts that
was a definite challenge every detail
has to be thought about and designed
based on what each planet was
our sets have gone over the top and
amazing
definitely make everybody feel like you
are in that world
going on those sets was awe-inspiring
they are just made so well
it was amazing to be in one of those
sets and feel like you're at home
i think we made something special and
we're all really excited for the
audience to experience
you